Dear President,
esteemed members of the delegation,
esteemed members of the press,
I greet you with my most heartfelt feelings.
I am very pleased to host Mr. Nilüftü and his delegation, President of Finland, in Ankara.
Once again, in your presence, I
welcome them to their delegation.
Two friends with good relations in the history of Turkey and Finland
Diplomatic relations established with the Friendship Agreement signed in 1924 have become
stronger in the last century or so.  In our
new tell me meetings, we
confirmed our joint will to develop Turkey-Finland relations. We
also
discussed the steps we will take in the coming period. Our
bilateral trade volume
exceeded 2 billion dollars last year.
We are ready to diversify our economic and commercial relations, especially in the fields of defense industry and tourism.
In our meetings, we
also discussed current regional and global issues, including Turkey-EU relations, as well as our bilateral relations.
We care about Finland's continued strong support for Turkey's European Union membership.  We
also made a commitment to opinions on the developments in the context of the war, our
efforts to stop the bloodshed and end the war through diplomatic means.  It is
a country that sacrificed its citizens to terrorism.
We are fighting simultaneously with the most bloody structures in the world, from Daesh to PKK and FETO. We are the
only NATO country on the right that defeated Daesh. We
believe that there is no place for any terrorist organization in the future of our region, regardless of its
name and the calculations behind it.  We are
determined to root out organizations that threaten the survival of our nation. We
also openly express our sensitivity and determination on this issue at every opportunity and
ground.
We evaluate NATO's enlargement process within the framework of these facts.  He
is one of the strong defenders of NATO's open-door policy. We
approved the start of the accession negotiations of Finland and Sweden at the NATO summit in Madrid.  We have seen that
Turkey has
taken sincere and concrete steps to
fulfill its commitments in the tripartite memorandum. Based on the sensitivity and progress achieved by our country in addressing security concerns, we decided
to initiate the approval process of Finland's NATO accession protocol in our parliament. I
wish this decision to be beneficial for our alliance, especially our countries.  In
this way,
I believe that meat will play a role in maintaining global security and stability.
With the completion of the approval process,
our relations with Finland will be
strengthened on the basis of NATO alliance. We
will continue our talks in Sweden on the basis of the principles of the alliance and our approach in the fight against terrorism.
I am of the opinion that his principles and goodwill in advancing the process are now more clearly seen, at
this point,
how the process will proceed will be
directly related to the concrete steps Sweden will take.  I would like to
thank the delegation once again for their visit
My Turkey is a warning pass 1 Lite
already this is
tomorrow's
already Ayhan
[Music]
Yes thank you, thank you,
questions are
a question from Finland A President from Turkey
or something and television
starts when Turkey is now Finland Sweden
You can give a concrete answer and
I will ask you the same question with your opinion, but
[Music]
dear friends, first of all, we
do not have a different approach towards Sweden,
but
Sweden has
embraced
terrorists.
We gave a list of around 120 terrorists, and we
said give them to
us, of course, Mr. Prime Minister is a good person.
But they did not give us these terrorists.
Since there were no such actions,
we had to separate Finland from Sweden, and
we showed our positive approach to Finland with our signature today, and it quickly
wrote from the Ministry of Foreign Affairs and came to me. I just sent the letter
to our parliament
And after that, the commission
will go to the general assembly from the commission.
I hope that if it grows before the election, it
will be good for our countries.
Yes, sorry, freemette from Turkey,
Hani Hop said,
Yes,
he drew a different path before Turkey. Let
's say good luck, however,
as of June, his own terror law
will come into effect in Sweden Do you think until then?
Could it be that Sweden delays Turkey's demands or is it waiting for the elections in Turkey
? Is there an option for
Sweden to still enter NATO as a member until the summit in July?
Is it on the table for Turkey?
I also said that Turkey
does not have a negative approach towards NATO's enlargement, but Turkey
has a red line especially in the fight against terrorism.  If
an organization
leaves Turkey alone in the fight against terrorism,
of course,
we, as Turkey, would not say yes to such countries.
I mean, we gave them
a terror list of 124 people as far as I remember,
but
there is no positive step taken by Sweden against this terror list.
I'm sorry if there is no step, Mr. Prime Minister
may be a good person, but the result is important for us,
as long as we do not see this result,
in the fight against terrorism, even
as long as there are such incidents, up to the infiltration of their parliament, our
approach will be the same as today.
Thank you
[Applause]